nada diplomática de alto voltaje la otan
reunía en bucarest en una cumbre de dos
días a los cancilleres de la alianza con
la Guerra de Ucrania como telón de fondo
presston el presidente Putin Está
tratando de usar el invierno como arma
para obligar a los ucranianos a
congelarse oír Está tratando de doblegar
la voluntad del valiente pueblo
ucraniano
people Estados Unidos entregará 53
millones de dólares para comprar equipos
de red eléctrica promesas a las que se
sumaron el resto de ministros de
exteriores para ayudar a Ucrania de
forma económica práctica y política la
alianza de la otan está brindando un
apoyo sin precedentes y hoy los aliados
hicieron compromisos adicionales para el
paquete de asistencia integral de la
otan para Ucrania
también hubo cumbre en Berlín los
ministros de Justicia del g7 se
reunieron por primera vez en la historia
lo hicieron junto a Fiscales de la Corte
Penal Internacional la Unión Europea y
ucra
nosotros como ucranianos entendemos que
el crimen de agresión como crimen
primario crimen de guerra primario
cometido por la federación de Rusia debe
ser punible a nivel internacional
seguros En ningún lugar donde podamos
detenerlos los llevaremos ante la
justicia en estricto cumplimiento del
principio de juicio justo ningún crimen
de guerra debe quedar impune Ese es el
mensaje hoy
todo esto cuando Rusia se retiró de las
conversaciones con Estados Unidos para
el desarme nuclear acusan a Washington
de un comportamiento antirruso tóxico